et sur le front diplomatique maintenant
on va voir ce qui se passe actuellement
on tend bien sûr de ne pas stopper le
dialogue avec vladimir poutine virginie
hertz bonjour on tente de ne pas stopper
ce dialogue avec le kremlin et
parallèlement à ça les initiatives se
multiplient pour tenter évidemment de
faire cesser cette guerre oui absolument
alors il ya un dialogue direct des
pourparlers directs entre les russes et
les ukrainiens la frontière biélorusse
qui ont permis notamment ce cessez le
feu qui tend qui tient tant bien que mal
aujourd'hui 12h de cessez-le-feu avec
des corridors humanitaires mais au-delà
de ça il ya des tentations tentative de
médiation internationale
e c'était il ya quelques jours c'était
le président chinois qui a dit être prêt
à une médiation internationale pareille
des propositions du côté d'israël mais
en fait ce qu'ils ont fait des
propositions les plus abouties ce sont
les turcs et demain d'ailleurs le
ministre des affaires étrangères turc va
recevoir ses homologues ukrainiens et
russes d'un côté ce sera dans la station
balnéaire d'antalya faut dire que la
turquie a une position vraiment
intermédiaire par lot 2 elle est membre
de l'otan elle elle fournit des drones
de combat aux ukrainiens aussi dont elle
parle aux ukrainiens les soutiens ces
drones de combat ukrainien bayraktar qui
sont devenus le symbole de la résistance
ukrainienne mais dans le côté c'est
aussi un pays qui ne s'est pas joint aux
sanctions occidentales qui a maintenu
son espace aérien ouvert à la russie et
surtout des voies maritimes
donc il n'a pas fermé les d3d du
bosphore et des dardanelles aux navires
militaires russes faut dire que la
turquie dépend en matière de gaz et une
énergie beaucoup de la russie et aussi
en matière de en matière de blé en tout
cas qu'est ce que va donner cette
rencontre ne s'est passé dans tout cas
une victoire pour le président turc le
président turc eux qui avait dit dès fin
février qui ne voulaient ni abandonné
qui est venu moscou et surtout qu'ils ne
voulaient pas céder sur les intérêts de
la turquie une position un peu d
équilibriste est ce que justement on
peut attendre quelque chose de cette
rencontre
alors si certaines entre tôt et il faut
être extrêmement prudent d'ailleurs les
ministres des affaires étrangères ou
même ce qu'il dit vont à cette rencontre
mais mais qu il ne faut pas s'attendre à
grand chose on connaît les prétentions
de vladimir poutine c'est les mêmes
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois un
statut neutre et non nucléaire pour les
crèmes c'est à dire pas d'adhésion à
l'otan des minéralisations obligatoire
reconnaissance de l'annexion de la
crimée souveraineté des régions
séparatistes et là dessus pour le moment
le président dira en ski a dit qu'il
était hors de question de discuter qu'il
pouvait éventuellement discuter sur une
plus grande autonomie des régions du
dôme bassil a dit je suis prêt au
dialogue mais nous ne sommes pas prêts à
capituler donc attendons de voir demain
c'est un dialogue qui est en train de
s'entamer doucement mais c'est
certainement pas demain qu'on va avoir
les premiers les résultats